the way that the biggest beliefs have  been broken for me have been one of two  ways reality proves me wrong or someone  tells me a story and gives me evidence  from their lives I remember we went to a  mastermind we were just starting out I  was not making a ton of money A guy got  up there he gave his little Spiel and  he's like yeah you know we're making  three or four hundred thousand dollars a  month I don't really know what I'm doing  the guy did not seem smart my actual  first thought was if he can do it I can  do it through evidence he reshaped my  reality it was one of the most momentous  thing I either have reality prove you  wrong or someone else is that reality  for you where they tell their story  about I used to think this thing and  then I will share my story so you don't  have to have the scar